okay four people joining this meeting
this is a weekly incremental language
development meeting for often language
as I've been saying in several of these
live streams the live streams I've been
bit sparse recently because we're
finishing version 12.1 on the one hand
and on the other hand I'm personally
deeply and intensely working on my
physics project which hopefully will see
the light of day fairly soon um alright
let's launch here um Brian is asking is
there an announcement date for my
physics project we were literally just
discussing that I think I'm gonna
predict mid-march um the um okay I wish
you know it's one of these things where
there's just a lot this first project
I'm just itching to tell people about it
but it's just there's a lot to say and
it'll get very very very confused if
it's not said in an organized way so we
are getting things ready and I hope it
will be very nicely presented and all
ready to go and I'm deeply impatient so
if you think you're impatient to get
this finished I'm a hundred times more
impatient than you are but um um okay
combinators yes I mean we talked about
those couple of weeks ago and got
sidetracked into evaluation control out
the most innermost evaluation stuff like
that
so I think here the idea would be to
just lay the groundwork to decide on the
name for the binary application and get
the design of the operator symbol on its
way and maybe we could even decide how
we would represent the basic
combinators okay so but but so what okay
so I've got several questions here I
mean what do we think we're going to do
with the combinators that is are they
going to Auto evaluate this is gonna be
an eval we learned that's 30 that is
impossible because I mean all the
interesting
have infinite evaluation chains so at
the moment it's just notation and then
we need a way to selectively apply those
standard oils for s and K say I would
like to apply them innermost or
outermost to apply them step by step
right so that turns into a
um I mean essentially we please repeat
it but maybe something that would allow
me I'll allow us to specify the order in
which these rules get applied because at
the moment I think it's undefined right
absolutely whether I see this question
live student from Ethan about can we
pull in the Google Calendar to that I I
think the answer is yes I think there's
a service connection that lets you do
that because I think it uses iCal format
I have not tried doing it don't now um I
think it should work through service
connect um okay they look this whole
business about how the evaluation done
is done that is the whole story really
of all of this I mean that's going to be
you know we can have a notation and
that's interesting
but what are we going to do with the
notation other than various kinds of
evaluation
and and I don't even know I mean some
things like Church numerals and so on
they will be stable they don't evaluate
they're just you know but there are
other things I don't even know whether
people try and do crazy stuff where
there's partial you know where there's
things that where you say I mean this is
very much of the you know one minus one
equals zero but one is represented by a
nonterminating Combinator expression yes
I mean if you look at the the fixed
point Combinator why I mean the basic
properties that
f no sorry bye of F turns into F of iOS
but it doesn't stop there so to actually
show that it does then you would have to
selectively apply it say just glide one
step at a time and whenever you have two
desired result you stop so I don't know
how much you can automate this I mean
you did some of these chains with s
terms in in NK s who are just to see
what happens but yes but you never
worried about the evaluation although
that makes obviously big has it became
impact on the size of the expressions
because if you do the innermost parts
first and they will usually go much
faster
what did I do do you know what I did for
evaluation order because I must have I
mean I did it yes you probably just use
replace repeat it or we place you know
yeah but I certainly knew about this
issue about evaluation so I will have
done had some control of evaluation
order um
you
that's pretty minimal that's using
replace yes but the behavior in the
course of the evolution can depend on
how accommodating rules are applied okay
so that's what I did yeah so that's
exactly we're exactly right so I this is
all I did I mean it's good for
identifying interesting cases
all right got lots of interesting cases
but um what do we think people gonna use
the Combinator stuff for other than
admiring I mean Combinator's I mean okay
so we have accommodated so first
question is you are proposing that we
have an infix form that will represent
something that corresponds to something
like this is that correct that we have a
left left associative form yes okay so
that would work for any functions I mean
that you could say F of um you know your
combinatorial application G etcetera
etcetera and it would compose it in this
way right yes I mean it doesn't do
anything it's very similar to for
example non commutative multiply right I
mean we just provide it for those who
want to do interesting stuff with it but
we don't actually do anything with it I
see you so you're not proposing the
thing evaluates to an off Combinator you
apply just sits there is just like non
commutative multiply
okay and the the operator form is just I
mean we need a way to represent it in
nice nice form without all these this
bunched up parentheses or brackets and
what are you proposing using small
circle or something or what what what
actual symbol about that I mean that's
actually difficult question I mean the
problem is that of course if you do if
you work in combinatory logic then you
do the same thing as you do in
arithmetic with multiplication you you
don't use any symbol right so but we
clearly need something on input and it's
representation is not that critical
because in output you wouldn't even see
it I just like the multiplication dot
but the circle some form of circle would
would certainly be possible okay but so
you're imagining people will
be typing this but how do they do that
with parentheses right they'll have a
occasional parentheses yeah mostly
common area flies and some parentheses I
mean if you look at the example that a
third one is an example where you need
two parentheses the ABC yes yes right
what are your right associating and the
middle one you don't need and so it
would it would remove them on input and
an output I mean it's it behaves exactly
the way lefty/lefty has exactly these
properties but it's not very nice simple
to use for this purpose
um Xylo Khan on our on a quorum our
livestream is pointing out the saying
that he worked on a project with Todd
Rowland about combinators that's cool um
um ah well we'd like to hear from silo
silo koron that's a good name um yeah um
look I think primary I mean you know
it's like a Turing machine function it's
I mean I mean I wonder well okay but the
question is are there actual practical
applications for Combinator's in 2020
100 years after they were invented you
know is there in fact anything useful
that we could expect to do but then we
would have to have automatic evaluation
you know a big nest of esters in case
isn't gonna do anybody any good it is
conceivable that there is piping along
lines of things like curry that could
actually be usefully gotten out of
Combinator's perhaps that Combinator is
all wait together with community yes
well but that's the point that the roman
is making that it's unclear what you
mean by that but the fact is that you
know when Shawn Finkel originally
invented these things he did it as a
form of piping just like we are using
curry as a form of piping that is to get
you know the argument of something into
the right place so to speak right and
Suez is that you know we have invented
certain kinds of piping and are these
useful go ahead you know I was thinking
that it would be a function needing a
second argument that parametrize is that
various forms for valuation I know but
those are
that as I was saying in a previous one
of these meetings you know look I looked
at this stuff what is it now forty years
ago and it was really complicated and a
certain amount was known I don't think a
lot more is known today it was super
hard to parameterize in a way that made
any sense now maybe we know more now and
we could parameterize it better but but
right now okay that's we shouldn't go
through this in great detail but I mean
imagine an evaluation front so to speak
as you go through this combinatory
expression it's got a tree it's got some
evaluation front where things are
happening right does that does that
picture makes sense Roman yes yes okay
okay so think about it like a
breadth-first search you're deciding
where you're gonna go next right it's
really hard to say that now by the way I
mean it so happens this comes up in the
physics project in connection with
affiliations of things like space-time
um where you know think about it like a
breadth-first search you're doing you
are as you I mean this is no let's not
let's not slide into talking about this
horrendously complicated topic but but
the main point is imagine you have an
evaluation front how do you parameterize
it
I mean even a very simple thing your
your you've got a grid of values like
you're doing an a command function like
evaluation and you've got this grid of
2-dimensional grid of values and you're
asked which should you do next right how
do you parameterize that I mean you
could do depth-first that's very clear
it's very clear what that means you can
do layers in some way where you do one
variable before they you know will you
go through you know all of the X values
for a given Y value right next Y value
etcetera etcetera etcetera you make
slices like that or you do other things
but how do you parameterize that I don't
know what I mean it's clear that in
theorem provers they must run into the
exact same problems right I mean theorem
provers try to get around these infinite
chains by cleverly restricting how deep
they go into various branches try to
find something useful that's a slightly
different thing so the theorem provers I
mean ok the reason I actually know
something about this now is because this
stuff is deeply relevant to this physics
project um and so in fact this is the
you know these become things like the
reference frames and the observer
specifications for artery in quantum
mechanics and things so it is a is it's
a you know the main bottom line is that
it's it's hard to parameterize in people
like an inertial frame in relativity is
a certain parameter ization that happens
to be really simple um
I think uh gosh um
what we're just asking you are asking
how do people parameterize it well few
approvers othor improve its yessssss
they don't what they're doing is that
they they kind of know they are trying
to establish an answer right and so what
they do
well you're saying the question is is
that if there is a fixed point can you
find it like that's the question and you
could go and generate immensely long
word
you know chains and go off and get lost
and never generate the fixed point right
and and the answer is I mean our theorem
prover our equation of logic theorem
prover can in fact we should look at
that
I think we have it don't we have a
Combinator axiom system than the theorem
prover okay but we certainly could have
so that is one approach to evaluation is
to say use the equation of logic theorem
prover right and see if we can find a
fixed point that way that's a
possibility
so I mean once we have this symbol we
could train this theorem prover to know
the properties of this symbol exactly
look the fact is you already know it to
lose in terms of practical programming
if the evaluator is a theorem prover you
know it will be unusable for anything
practical ways you have no idea how long
it's gonna take
it's certainly and it will be able it
would be able to prove on in some of the
cases maybe theorem provers with your
inner systems typically the process is
very targeted to specify very basically
exactly where you want things to happen
step by step right we can still do
useful stuff like with doing machines I
mean we know that it's undecidable but
it can still for example look for busy
beavers and yes but I think we could we
could have good support for for
experimenting with with combinatory
terms fine well okay so look the main
point is what does the evaluator do
right and what you're suggesting is we
have several forms of evaluator one form
evaluator might be the theorem proving
evaluator where it uses the best methods
we have to try and find a fix point
using theorem proving another method
might
depth-first evaluator so maybe the right
thing to do is we could have a
Combinator evaluate which has a second
argument which is the strategy to use
and we just have some named strategies
yes but that wouldn't even be here
strictly to Combinator's I tell me the
same thing is useful just pretty much
everywhere no because for the theorem
proving one we have to have the axiom
system and oh no I mean the the oil
based one what I mean a kind of replace
repeat it with some smarts built in
would be useful not only for it would be
useful but but I'm telling you I'm
telling you that isn't a good it's very
hard to parameterize I mean I think it's
a very interesting language design
problem and it is related to our
questions about handling on evaluated
code but I think it's a hard problem I
think we should okay so with respect to
this look let's at least do the curation
to find the definitions of all all sorts
of famous Combinator's okay that's easy
enough and let's plan to put in the
syntactic form to deal with Combinator
apply yes then we need to decide on the
name of a common level to apply I think
Jenny combinate or apply or Combinator
or what would be the right what is the
right version of this it isn't really
apply is it well I mean I blinds all
there is right I mean there's only one
operation and I mean it's called
combinatory logic Combinator II
terms so it's kind of I know but
combinatory is that we tend to avoid
don't even know what the English
description of him I think we should
just call it Combinator reply and
Combinator evaluate what do you think
combinatory just sounds like dilatation
as opposed to dilation um those tutorial
but then I think you know somebody
should do the curation task of just
collecting the definitions of all these
things the other thing we want is
something which will take a string a
traditional combinatory logic string and
just parse it yes I mean that could be
there could be a resource function I
mean that or we wait until we have a
passage anyway to the language well I
think we should have just like with
regular expressions we should be able to
do it I mean I mean it's not it's not
difficult right um and I mean that said
I have there s kic BWI that's pretty
much what we need I mean I mean there
might be others I mean you probably
already did more research on this on the
origin of all of these well I mean
Raymond smullin has the sole book of
Combinator you know here's this whole
book of birds which has do we use the
traditional named constants or do we
just call them Combinator ice Combinator
K Combinator hi I'm just calling
Combinator SK whatever yes
um yeah so we don't have to hockey about
who invented them first no we do not
because we'll never get the answer to
that because I mean I I do know enough
about this to know that it's a bit
complicated all right listen I you know
I don't really know what other than it's
a cool thing to do at the hundredth
anniversary of combinators I'm not sure
that this is going to be a practical you
know look it's one of these things where
if we get them implemented nicely it may
turn out to be more practical than we
think but in a hundred years it hasn't
turned out to be that practical yet um
all right let's let's move on here
because I think we've got somebody's
pointing out things about southern
retort oh wow I don't know anything
about this I don't know what this is
okay that's a picture of lizard I like
that
um I'm sorry can we discuss for a moment
a possible precedence that this thing
could have so that we can get moving the
process of this symbol lots of musing
this is a neuron that's meet several
times that's kind of cool okay um
precedence I don't know did you did you
have a proposed precedence in here so so
I think this should be compared to add
and composition and both are very close
together in the table so just a matter
of deciding what to put it
relation to them so if you say F I mean
let's call this I know what we're
calling it I mean if you say F dot G at
X I would assume that you want that to
group like this now that you want to
turn that into let's see the F dot G the
grouping F G H is a left application
grouping right so what does that turn
into oh you mean you mean that no I I
was thinking about the parentheses I
mean no I mean in terms of function
functional application what does it turn
into yes another bracket H like this
well I would thoroughly expect that if I
did at X I would thoroughly expect that
to be that thing of X so I would expect
it to be more tightly binding than than
at
okay so what do i well so what would we
think about composition so composition
if I say F at star G of X what how does
that bind even that binds with the Alpha
goodness sake
right at line 3 the strange right it's
really crazy I don't understand that at
all to try G of X rather than bracket of
X because the bracket is already there
sorry what are you saying so yes this is
the example we wrote on the left hand
side so try the same thing but instead
of bracket X bracket at X okay that's
correct yeah I mean this one has
confused me multiple times this this
precedence here the problem is if you
have it so high precedence that it's
higher precedence than the function
application it peels off all kinds of
crazy things I think that's terrible
once X is there G of X is treated as a
function ok so the question is between
this and the dot where is it where is
the dot go route or whatever it is
relative to this do you have a proposal
for that
I mean composition doesn't talk doesn't
interact to accommodate your application
so can we be the same presidents like
like this is for writing letter
composition I think that is closer to
add than to composition so probably we
should put these dot precisely between
ad and composition are you sure not
completely but to me applies is it's a
it's a form of that all right well then
then maybe it should be the same I don't
understand if it
same precedence I don't understand the
associativity z' what what what's the
associativity of composition right it's
left that's left associative isn't it
well composition is flat sorry we don't
matter in DNA yes okay but it is but
this commentary apply is not flat it's
less yeah I don't know the interaction
between something of the same precedence
that's flat versus left associated I
think if we make it exactly like at then
the first one will win what the right
comes look I don't know why don't you
try some things and then try try making
a bunch of test cases and see what
happens all right splice
yeah I'm still okay with splice okay so
that's that's okay great extract to the
default element yes so I think this is
an an interesting idea and in fact I
wanted to show that I have that function
internally for for you see not some
places they think I'm not sure about is
the fact that in other cases in which we
had a default element we ended up as in
hold cross attribute which I don't like
very much why well because people
thought that you might want to have
default element which self wrote for
example I don't know that I thought so
so this is a whole dress thing yes first
became whole dress just to support that
in hey I think extractors should not be
told something I agree I think it's a
mistake for us to be that way right so
an alternative if people want to throw
things from this default element the
leaders have put a function
having the object itself we have the
function that takes for example in
extract the position and this and
returns the object to be placed there
I'm sorry I didn't understand that so
how would you get around the first thing
so I mean yes sorry
imagine that instead of X we've had a
function f and then rather than return X
well I mean the other possibility would
be some form of thing like this because
the main issue is this is okay I mean
this is like if right but this okay so
you would argue if so the point here
would be a generic wrapper which says I
mean you know this is in the family of
splice nothing etc etc this is a a
generic wrapper is it semantically well
defined that if it's used will unpack
itself but otherwise will not I mean
that's somewhat similar the way that
delayed is used in web deployments to me
that seems like a better solution I mean
to have some general mechanism which
says certain functions can take things
which are delayed what other functions
might take that I mean and so generally
the thing would just be I mean delayed
we have what would be the semantics of
it the semantics would be yeah I mean
the semantics are just defined by the
function just like nothing and you know
the you know despite it eyes attack I
really think that this idea of splicer
ball is a good idea for functions that
we can use splices
as a way of inserting things into a
variety of functions by just defining
those functions to be splice herbal just
like we've been very successful with
numeric and with listable both of which
are just like do the right thing type
attributes somehow with splice it feels
as if the important thing is to specify
inside the sprite itself
what's the heading too much truth splice
just an independent direction it's an
independent direction right but I think
that the auto splicing is really
worthwhile I think people will find it
really useful so I mean Auto D delaying
would be another thing I personally I
think this is the right kind of approach
and it will be I think worthwhile to
review our various functions for which
ones could take this I mean what you
know these are things where there is a
what is the characteristic it is I think
it's a default element for extraction
when the element doesn't exist that
specific I mean I think it's very
specific we have at the same programming
look up and look up also got a hold
attribute to solve this type of horrible
yeah and we have had well it's horrible
we shouldn't you know I don't know how
these things happen because we never I
mean I would never have approved that
that oh gosh whatever it's a mistake
it's a mistake we shouldn't do that yeah
extractors are functions that have to do
their thing immediately without any
delayed form an extract in particular we
cannot have so let's look at the idea of
delight okay um and again let's
inventory what other functions could use
it in what about this alternative of a
function that would take the position
that's a bit more flexible because
function itself has a hold a tribute so
whatever we put inside is safe and gives
this freedom of or I'm going to use a
different default at different positions
I see I mean it's a nuisance
I think people because I think most
often they're just going to want to put
a particular thing there and it would be
just function of death thing but I mean
we crossed that bridge a little bit with
already putting first I agree that the
function thing is an interesting idea
and I mean we could conceal with you
that with an option what options we have
such things missing yes hmm okay look
let's inventory where we could use this
delight then where we've already got
things like this whether we could use a
missing behavior option you know I think
we need some more information
me and side-effect stuff um so the main
thing here was to point out this
alternative implementation they will
want to find interesting so I think the
idea is to do repeatedly things with a
test and the same idea was suggested in
this function repository function table
1 and it has the freedom of having a
different test parable to find quite
interesting which one
the function of the function repository
tape table one so I guess the sister has
to modify a bit just suggestion of a
repeat test to this other type of
approach of Table one and I think we
have discussed all the times these the
idea is to generalize the iterator
language to include conditions yeah by
the way Ethan is asking on a live stream
about your on that stuff and I I don't
know why the the maybe the neuron that
team should do a session with with
people I think it would be interesting
so I can we get Devon can you get that
suggestion made please yeah sherry I can
sorted um and otherwise yeah we could I
don't know why we haven't been live
streaming those meetings actually I
think some of them have been very some
of them are pretty pretty procedural but
but um that's another thing we should
put on the list is to livestream the
machine learning update meeting um
there's lots of stuff going on so it's
just not not not so visible okay so the
question is adding conditions to
iteration constructs and is is the
proposal here to generally have
something which is some kind of
condition in an iterator that seems
complicated it's yes I do agree I guess
my point is is trying to get something a
bit more powerful than and the ideas
well I mean the obvious thing to do is
to replace the list iterator with
something else
called you know conditional iterator or
something where that's a bad name but in
wherever we could have a list in table
or whatever to be able to have that
symbolic object or alternatively um see
because you know an iterator has several
pieces I mean an iterator you could as
well have a function that says I don't
know you know square the variable each
time or something okay but the basic
category here is to make up the iterator
is more sophisticated but then the other
question is in terms of the termination
condition what information do you have
it when you test the termination
condition right because our iterators
have the feature that they have
everything in scope which means they
might have a previous iterative value
they don't for example have the value of
the payload talking about iterators in
terms in in the sense of object-oriented
languages right when you have something
that says create is iterator and every
time you call it it produces next value
until it tells you that it's that it's
done that is a very powerful concept
which we don't have
yes we have had meetings about that
alternative approach and that's more
powerful than this this existing is
simpler it's just having this test which
gets the value of what has been produced
not the value of I itself but the value
of the payload of stable at each Atari
yeah I don't yeah I mean in Romans point
about um okay so I mean Romans point is
just have a function that you call on
what
to get the next value what do you what
do you provide it
doesn't have any arguments I mean oh
that's that that might work in a
language where you just have random
variables flapping around but in a
family it has it has internal state I
mean it's you you have to you create an
iterator for example you might create an
iterator that produces primes and once
created that iterator is a parameter
less function that every time you call
it you put your sister next value no I
understand that but that's different
from what we're doing here where you
have an iterator where we have a
two-step thing where we have an
iteration variable that is then used for
a to evaluate a payload
oh man you would then apply a function
to that iterator to put use I understand
a completely different style of
programming than what we have yes yes I
mean the case that we have
look really the correct thing here is
actually something different I mean the
correct thing would be some kind of
thing that says table and then you know
something like I don't know something
like this value while this is probably
not quite right but I mean something I
mean right now I don't even know what it
does what does it do if you say table
returned if I greater than six returned
I I mean again this is very non what
does this do and I would recommend that
we seduce okay but I mean so okay so
you're proposing so there if we do throw
cash you say this is gonna be six
whatever okay but now my question is
what if I wanted there to be a condition
that caused the table to terminate right
I keep tabeling up until that condition
is hit and then in effect it's returning
a bunch of nothings after that I mean I
could do that right now I could say
table if you know I greater than six
nothing otherwise I right but so you
know another possibility is to have
something in the payload that causes
early termination now that might cause
trouble because we can predict right now
how big a table is going to be whereas
if we do that we cannot predict anymore
but if you return nothing you won't be
able to predict either well nothing's
are removed a posteriori
yes right but I mean so that the
question is what is the difference
between putting it in the iterator and
putting it in the payload and if we're
going to have a function applied to the
payload I'd prefer to have it with the
payload because if we put it with the
payload we fully expect that the thing
will have access to the payload value
and I and J and the Israeli variables
basically that would be the natural
thing to have it have I guess it was
trained to align these Swit take a while
and for a while
yes handler on our live stream is asking
what happened to his idea about
associations in iterators what has
happened to that um we had a couple of
meetings in their SEC
serious I think this it's still under
evaluation I say okay fine just a
different branch
I don't know I think this is the wrong
time in our cycle so to speak to to
solve this problem I think that the I
mean with respect to this okay look
there's decorating the iterator that
Network decorating our iterators there's
decorating the payload and there's
completely different approaches like the
iterative function approach I think it's
worth looking at decorating the payload
I mean I'm thinking
I mean look clearly for some things
decorating the payload is easy like for
example if I do this you know that's
easy right I mean honestly this is
pretty easy too but well this doesn't
cause termination this just causes yeah
I mean it's horribly inefficient
yeah but yes I mean there should be
something like returned that actually
tells it to stop
right
Sanders commenting on things better
decorate iterator problem if you
decorate the iterator is it's unclear
what you get fed and whether you get fed
for example the values of iterators well
you get fed only values of iterators
within that iterator in the hierarchy so
it's so for example you can say i comma
10 i comma j because by the time sorry
no J comma 10 I comma J because
when Jays termination condition is
tested you already know the value of I
and so one of the claims would be when
any of those are tested do you know the
the sort of triangular inner values of
the traitors and do you also know the
payload value and unfortunately in these
cases just you know you just have as
essentially evaluation of variables the
values of the iterator variables but
then to get the payload we presumably
have to apply a function because we're
not supplying the payload as you know a
dollar payload value or something value
thing you know what I think this is not
the time to solve this problem I I think
it's some somebody's asking about
automatic differentiation yes it is
being worked on um and it is an
interesting language design problem very
interesting language design problem
which we will no doubt discuss in future
live streams all right well this has
been a little bit of a little bit of a a
thin meeting um but yeah will these will
thicken up greatly once-once 12.1 is is
out the door and once I have a bit more
time to devote to these kinds of things
um okay let me go back to trying to
figure out the evaluation scheme for for
the universe so to speak which turns out
to be shockingly similar to the problems
that we have here and hard um alright so
talk to you all soon then bye-bye